new federal mandate expected to roll out
quite soon as a result of president
biden's announcement last week christian
kosovo is joining us live in studio
christian you were on today's covet call
with health officials what do we know
now about these changes well brian
health officials say president biden's
mandates align with nevadas but they're
also awaiting clarification on some
issues including of course the rollout
of a copa 19 vaccine
the state of nevada is looking forward
to learning more about the rollout
process when it comes to booster shots
during a meeting today health officials
said they're relying on current
recommendations as they always do we
will be watching that closely and then
as we have done with
all other
emergency use and the age ranges and and
all of those things that we've been
really supporting
we've gotten from that federal level so
we will be watching what their
recommendations will be in terms of the
new federal mandates we know that it
will impact millions of employees across
the country specifically 1500 businesses
in nevada those details coming soon
well employers that don't comply could
face penalties of over 10 thousand
dollars per violation christian casa
does 8 news now